hey i'm arlo parks today i'm with
buzzfeed to revisit the past and build a
playlist of my favorite songs from when
i was a teenager
if you want to listen along click the
description box to access my playlist
[Music]
i'm 20 years old now so i was actually
a teenager only a few months ago i was
living in
west london in hammersmith which is
where i've been all my life
i was an awkward kid but i was a happy
kid my teenage years is kind of where i
started coming into myself and
discovering music and art and film and
books and
i was very much in with the like very
studious kids like he spent a lot of
time at the library that was my vibe
and then when i got to college i started
kind of partying a bit more
and expanding my social circles i was
definitely part of like the artsy kids
group and that's when i started hanging
around with people who loved making
beats who wanted to be directors and
designers and
found my people i guess i mean i was
always completely enthralled by music
ever since i was a really small kid like
i remember
my dad telling me the story of when i
was about one years old every time he
would stir
his coffee and it would make this little
rhythm and i would like do a little
dance so ever since i was a kid i've
always been
enjoyed by music and it was very much my
safe space
you know something that i'd listened to
by myself when i was feeling low or when
i was feeling excited
so my first election is charm by l
sweatshirt
i remember falling in love with the
album doris when i was 14 or 15 years
old
there was something so gritty to this
song there's something so introspective
and he's exploring
his relationship with his race his
family
um the whole hook is probably one of my
favorite hooks
of all time the first line of that is
something sinister to it
pendulum swinging slow a degenerate
moving and it's like
that sense of time slowing down when
you're in a difficult place
and there's this really raw sense of
darkness to that song that i love
it reminds me of sitting in my bedroom
right here where i
am now and just feeling a little bit
lost
feeling like i wasn't quite sure of my
direction and knowing that i wanted to
be a creative but being slightly unsure
as to how to get there and reminds me of
feeling a bit
confused but also hopeful and super
inspired my second song selection
is no surprises by radiohead radiohead
is one of my favorite bands of all time
and i discovered okay computer when i
was probably about
14 or so again there was something so
angsty to this record it's a record that
surrounds melancholy and alienation and
that first line you know a heart that
fills up like a landfill a job that
slowly kills you was like
like it was a hit and tom york's voice
was so
graceful and delicate and fragile almost
and the whole of radiohead's catalog
really taught me the idea of evolving as
an artist
it it kind of brings back that like
teenage angst when you're walking home
from school and you're kind of feeling
like no one understands you
and you're just wandering like lonely as
a cloud and feeling like
a little bit cool because you're
listening to this edgy band that no one
else in your class knows
i don't know that song feels soaring it
always lifted me up
next i've got figure eight by fk twigs
and the reason why i love
this song is that it's so kind of
confident in how
sensual and physical it is it's very
kind of muscular as a song and i
remember
listening to those synths and feeling
like it somehow got to the core of me
and it kind of reminds me of like
getting ready for a party
and then like putting it on with my
friends and we would like feel like we
were just in a movie
like we were just like getting ready
like we would walk in slow motion into
the party obviously we were like 15 and
awkward
um but that's the memory that comes back
to me when i think about that tune
what her music taught me is that idea of
experimentation
of fluidity also work ethic everything i
see on her social media she's always
honing her craft and her martial arts
and
her choreography are so ambitious and i
think it
kind of showed me that there are no
boundaries when it comes to music in the
worlds you can create
out getting ribs by king cruel is my
next election
and this album is probably one of the
most important albums when it comes to
who arlo parks is and
how she came to be there's something so
distinctly
london about this record it's poetic
it's gritty it's rough around the edges
and it really inspired me to start
making music
in my bedroom because i was listening to
his voice and it felt so unique and i
was listening to the instrumentation and
it was quite
sparse and minimal and it felt like he
had made it in his bedroom and that was
something that really drew me to his
music
and there's this little kind of sample
at the beginning and this guitar run and
it just reminds me
of walking home from school with a
friend of mine
and just feeling free i think what's
beautiful about those teenage years is
that there are those moments where you
feel
completely infinite and unstoppable and
you're like we're going to rule the
world someday and that's what outgetting
ribs reminds me
next up we've got yonkers by tyler the
creator
when i was younger i was an unabashed
odd future fan i loved how
provocative and playful and weird the
music was and i remember
this is one of the first raps that i
learned completely off by heart
and it's a very dark one um but
i remember that being something so
confident about his delivery
and the way the beat was kind of
creaking it was almost
gothic but it was also hip-hop and it
was this really interesting
fusion and i found it so exciting um and
tyler the creators definitely had a big
impact on my work
in terms of how versatile he is and the
places he explores with his production
up next juicy by biggie this song
ignited my love
of hop i think i heard this song when i
was pretty young
i think i must have been 30 in 12 or 13.
there was something so inspiring about
the storytelling
like i remember listening to it over and
over again
until i was just like wrapping it in the
kitchen and i told it to my little
brother
as well so even now whenever we hear
that song we just like
we know it word for word the story
behind that song you know
his ascent took the fame and building
his way up from the bottom i found it so
inspiring and the production
felt so nostalgic for a time that i
wasn't even
alive in it was a song that i grew to
when i was by myself and feeling a
little bit down
and his flow is literally like butter
the drums in hip-hop is something that i
really hold it to my heart how crunchy
they are
those kind of repeated loops you can
hear that influence in my music
so next up we've got special affair by
the internet
and i remember when i first discovered
this band i was in love with every
single member hearing sid's voice and it
was so it was like honey just like
floating towards me and i got obsessed
with that whole record ego death
i went to see them when i went to
reading festival i was 15
and i saw them live and i loved those
kind of psychedelic influences it felt
like i was dreaming or i was floating
even just seeing like these kind of
slightly indie edgy like black kids just
doing their thing
felt so inspiring to me as like a little
weird kid in the corner so
i was super inspired by watching them
play so next we've got
teenagers by my chemical romance i was a
big fan of my chemical romance when i
was a kid
especially like welcome to the black
parade and
this song was like the epitome of those
moments where you were just raging
against everything and i would just put
my headphones on my massive headphones
with my little like ipod nano and i
would stomp around i would like stop by
the river
and be like no one understands me it was
like the quintessential song
for like sulking essentially i had a big
phase where they were all i would listen
to them and fall out boy
and good charlotte as well so i was
definitely one of those kids because i
remember
loving like loving jared way with my
whole heart
like all of it and my last choice is
milk teas by keaton hanson
and this is a very kind of quiet soft
song
it encouraged me to kind of tap into
that vulnerable side of myself
and led to me discovering artists like
elliot smith and sophie and stevens
i think it reminds me of those moments
where i was just in my room
feeling a little bit frustrated and
keaton pence's voice has this very
soothing quality
it made me somehow feel like everything
was going to be all right so although
it's quite sad and delicate
i've got lovely memories of listening to
this and feeling like
things might work out in the end and
that's my ultimate playlist from my
teenage years
let me know what you thought in the
comments below and don't forget to check
out my newest album collapsed in
sunbeams
[Music]
you